over 2000 episodes Joe Rogan has never
paid a guest to be on his show but he
just offered someone one hundred
thousand dollars to come debate Robert
Kennedy Jr Peter hota has accused RFK of
spreading misinformation during a recent
JRE appearance to which Joe responded by
saying quote if you can claim what RFK
is saying his misinformation I'm
offering you 100 Grand to the charity of
your choice if you're willing to debate
him on my show with no time limit Peter
Hotes replied you have my cell phone and
email I'm always willing to speak with
you Joe Rogan responded promptly by
saying this is a non-answer I challenged
you publicly because you publicly agreed
with that dog Vice article if
you're really serious about what you
stand for you now have a massive
opportunity for a debate that will reach
the largest audience a discussion like
this has ever had if you think someone
else is better qualified suggest that
person then Elon Musk replied to that
tweet saying he's afraid of a public
debate because he knows he's wrong show
Rogan then took his kill shot by pulling
out the screenshot of a tweet that Hotes
had just shamefully deleted seconds
after posting where he demanded Joe put
up 50 million dollars the current offer
for Peter Hotes to appear on JRE is up
over a million dollars but it looks like
the Charities should not be expecting
that money anytime soon as it's very
doubtful Peter